Okay, as I mentioned in the message, this
shiur is for the refuah sheleima of my
good friend and neighbor David Henoch Mordechai ben
Freda Simcha, she-yehiye refuah sheleima, and he should
enjoy the divrei Torah as well. Okay, so
as advertised, we're giving the shiur on Yom
Tov Sheini on keeping the second day of
Yom Tov, which as we know, in Chutz
La'aretz, we keep Yom Tov Sheini. So obviously
everyone wants to know, and the controversial stuff
is about keeping Yom Tov Sheini when you're
visiting Israel or when you're in yeshiva in
Israel, but we're going to give a little
background first, understand Yom Tov Sheini in general
and then apply it, then address the issue
of the visitors to Eretz Yisrael. So just
quickly, I gave the sources in somewhat length,
I can't read every word here, but if
on Shavuos, if you want to learn something,
this might be a good topic, Shavuos night,
to look into a little bit further. But
we begin with the Gemara in Beitzah, the
Gemara in Daf Dalet in Beitzah tells us
the following Mishnah: Berishonah Hayu and if you
have any questions at any time, please feel
free to reach out with the question. Detnan
Berishonah Hayu Masi'in Massu'os. Originally they would make
torches, right we know that where is Rosh
Chodesh declared? Rosh Chodesh is declared in Yerushalayim,
right here actually, right outside our window over
here, at the Beis HaMikdash. Who knows the
place where the Sanhedrin sat? What was it
called? No, in they had a particular chamber
in the Beis HaMikdash known as the next
to the Beis HaMikdash, yeah, the Lishkas HaGazis
on Har HaBayis, known as the Lishkas HaGazis,
Lishkas HaGazis where this the chamber where they
sat and they would pasken shailos and they
would declare Rosh Chodesh when witnesses would come
running to Yerushalayim to tell them they've seen
the new moon and Beis Din would declare
Rosh Chodesh. The famous song Ki MiTzion Teitzei
Torah, that's a big part of it, Ki
MiTzion Teitzei Torah. It's from Tzion, from Yerushalayim
comes the Torah, comes the declaration of the
Rosh Chodesh, which of course impacts when Yom
Tov is going to be. Now how did
they get the word out? They didn't have
text messaging back in the day, so what
did they do? Hayu Masi'in Massu'os. They would
make torches, they would light torches on the
hills from going from Yerushalayim and around the
world, and that way they would light torch
after torch after torch where they would see
the torch and keep on going, and the
whole world would know that Rosh Chodesh had
been declared. Nice system, it'd probably move pretty
quickly. You see the torch, the next one
makes a torch, next one makes a torch,
within a couple days everyone knows that it
is Yom Tov, it is Rosh Chodesh, and
then you'll know when Yom Tov is. Mishekilkelu
HaKusim and the Kusim started to mess things
up, they started to play around with the
fires and try to mess up our messaging
system, so they had a cyber attack
of that time, of those days, the virus
of those days, so what did they do?
Hitkinu She-ihyu Shluchin Yotzim. Okay, what choice do
they have? They have to do it manually,
i.e., they had to send out messengers. Messengers
had to go out from Yerushalayim to all
over the world. But what? Right? ve-ilu bitlu
Kusim avidnan chad yoma. If the Kusim would
stop, they would do one day, and also
when wherever the shluchim, wherever the messengers would
arrive, they would keep one day. The problem
was sometimes it would take two, three, or
four weeks to get to certain places physically
in the Gola. And why is that an
issue? That is an issue because on Sukkos
and on Pesach, the 15th of the month,
two weeks after Rosh Chodesh is Yom Tov.
Two weeks after Rosh Chodesh is Yom Tov,
and if you didn't know, every month could
be 29 days or could be 30 days.
So when you get when 29 days of
a month were passed, so that first that
next day could be Rosh Chodesh, but it
could also be the last day of the
previous month and would mean the next day
is Rosh Chodesh. So now you didn't know
if Rosh Chodesh had been after a 29-day
month or a 30-day month, which means you
don't know if Pesach should start on what
you think is the 15th day or maybe
on the 16th day, because if the last
month had an extra day, Yom Tov would
be a day later. Sukkos or Pesach would
be a day later. And so now here
you are in the Gola, you don't know
when they declared Rosh Chodesh, and therefore you
would have to keep two days. If you
were not sure, you'd have to keep two
days. That's, that's what the Gemara says. That's
was the story of keeping two days, so
they really didn't know, they really didn't know
when Yom Tov was. Now the Gemara has
a question. We all know nowadays that we
don't have this system, and it was in
fact already in the days of the Gemara
that they didn't have this system, where they
rather, they had a set calendar. Hillel HaSheini
figured out a whole system and he was
able to say forever what would be the
calendar. So the Gemara asks: Ve-hasha de-yad'inan be-kvi'a
de-yarcha. Now that we know the calendar, this
whole thing doesn't make any sense anymore. We
don't live in a time where we're waiting
for people to come from Beis Din, we
don't know if they show up. In those
days, yes, in those days it made a
lot of sense to keep two days of
Yom Tov. Of course you had to keep
two days of Yom Tov. Nowadays we know...
avdinan trei yomei? So says the Gemara, why
are we doing two days? What's the deal?
The Gemara answers, mishum deshalchu mitam, they sent
from there, they sent from Eretz Yisrael, hizaharu
beminhag avoseichem beyadeichem. You in the Galus, maintain
the custom of your forefathers. Maintain your custom
to keep two days. Why? zimnin degazru shamda
ve'asi leakalkulei, because there are times that the
non-Jews, non-Jewish rulers will declare some kind of
decree against you and things are going to
get messed up. So in order to, because
there might be a situation where keeping two
days will go back to being absolutely necessary
because there will be a real doubt, maintain
that practice so that everyone knows what to
do in case it becomes necessary to keep
two days. That's what the Gemara conclusion is
and that's what we do until today. We
keep two days because of this concern. I
saw Rav Emden so points out in his
Mishnah Berurah that there were times in Jewish
history when this happened. You had Russians who
were in the Soviet Union who were in
imprisoned in Siberia, they literally did not have
access to calendars. They had no idea, certainly
not a Jewish calendar. They wanted to eradicate
Judaism so they did not know, they couldn't
keep track of the months. And the reason
by the way it's twenty-nine or thirty, thirty
is because the lunar cycle is twenty-nine and
a half days and a little bit, a
little bit over twenty-nine and a half days.
So over a twelve month period, you need
to have six and six of twenty-nine and
thirty. Okay, taking into account leap years and
various things, so there's a lot of details
of keeping the lunar calendar in line with
the solar calendar, which is what we have.
At the bottom line is you don't know
if the month is twenty-nine or thirty days.
And Rav Emden pointed out there were times
in our history, recent history, that Jewish people
kept two days mamash out of safek. So
this is what the Gemara says, we want
to maintain that practice for that time, should
that time come, that we'll have to keep
two days for real. That's what the Gemara
says. And the, you know, just to point
out, it's a big deal. We're talking about,
imagine if you messed up Pesach and you
ate chametz on Pesach. That's a very big
deal, issur, to eat chametz on Pesach, it's
kareis to eat chametz on Pesach. So we
want to put in protections to make sure
people don't come to a situation where they're
going to violate Yom Tov and potentially chametz
on Pesach, etc. And that's what the Rambam
says. The Rambam says in source two, I'm
not going to read inside, but that this
is a takanah. That what, second, I'll get
to your question, that what the Gemara means
is that they decreed a takanah that midrabonon,
everyone in the Galus, everyone outside of Israel
is required to keep two days. Why? Because
of this concern that they might forget about
it. And it seems to be linked somehow
to people who in Eretz Yisrael, Chutz La'aretz,
because in Chutz La'aretz anyway there was, existed
a practice, people used to keep two days
when there was a time you had to
keep two days. So in those places where
such a practice existed, you should keep, you
should hold on to that practice in order
to be prepared for potential need in the
future. Yes, Zach. If you were where the
practice was two days, eventually they would find
out which day it was, correct? Correct. So
then for Shavuot, which is not defined as
a certain date... That's an excellent question. That's
an excellent question. I have a sefer here
on the Rosh Hashanah, I don't remember what
he says about that, we'll look it up
after. That is a good question. Now, says
the Shulchan Aruch. Shulchan Aruch says in source
three, begallus she'ossin sheinei yamim tovim missafek kol
mah she'assur barishon assur basheini. In, now just
to take a step back for a second,
Yom Tov Sheini is, what's Yom Tov Sheini?
It's a safek. In the old days it
was a safek, but nowadays we know, it's
not even a safek. We know that the
second day of Yom Tov is not Yom
Tov. So we're just doing it out of
a gezeirah, out of a concern that you
might need it in the future, so you
keep it. So says the Shulchan Aruch, nevertheless
there are no differences. Anything that's prohibited on
Yom Tov Rishon, you have to prohibit on
Yom Tov Sheini. You make no distinctions in
what you would do. vehayu menadin lemi shemezalzel
bo, they would excommunicate people that would take
Yom Tov Sheini lightly. And the Rashba points
out... sorry, the Mishnah Berurah explains here in
source four that there was really great concern,
here's where the Mishnah Berurah mentions the chametz
on Pesach issue, and so they went, they
took it very, very seriously because of the
potential that what it could lead to. The
Rashba points out, think about this for a
second. There's a mitzvah every day to put
on tefillin. There's a mitzvah every day to
put on tefillin. On Yom Tov... next week
on Monday, min hatorah, you have the mitzvah
to put on tefillin. Says the Rashba, look
how far Chazal went. They said don't do
a mitzvah. Don't do a mitzvah of putting
on tefillin, which they have a right to
do. yesh koach beyad chachamim la'akor davar min
hatorah beshev ve'al ta'aseh, Chachamim have the ability
to uproot something from the Torah in a
passive manner. They're telling you don't do a
mitzvah, they have a right to do that.
But that's how far it goes. You're not
going to even put on tefillin. So... Okay,
that's a little bit of background of Yom
Tov Sheini, how serious Yom Tov Sheini is
taken. The background of it is not seemingly
that so serious, but it's a gezeirah in
order to make sure it gets enforced. Chazal
took it very, very seriously, and until today
one should not take it lightly. Perhaps a
little bit of machshavah behind this that I
saw this brought down in this sefer that
I mentioned Yom Tov Sheini Kehilchato. The halachos
and hashkafos of Yom Tov Sheini brings down
a nice idea. We know that Yom Tov,
anybody learned Derech Hashem, but all many mussar
sefarim and shmuessen talk about this, that when
you experience a Yom Tov, on the Yom
Tov you're tapping into the kochos, to the
power of that day, to the feelings of
that day. Right? When we go, we leave
Mitzrayim, so we're supposed to go tap back
into that idea of leaving servitude to others,
to Paroh, to other non-spiritual things and transferring
our servitude to God. With Sukkos, the experience
of Hashem divine providence over us and watching
us with the Ananei Hakavod. Every Yom Tov
we're supposed to feel those feelings. So says,
he says here in the sefer, perhaps we
can say the following idea. That in we
all know in Eretz Yisrael we can all
feel, I think we've all experienced a higher
spiritual connection. That's because the pasuk says in
Eretz Yisrael it's tamid einei Hashem Elokecha bah.
Eretz Yisrael is a land where God's eyes
are always watching. What does that mean? That
means that okay, getting into a little Kabbalah
right here, but Hashem is everywhere, yet Hashem
hides himself in order for this world to
exist, a physical world shouldn't be able to
exist in God's spiritual spiritual world. So God
hides himself, but there's certain places where God
is less hidden. Eretz Yisrael is one of
those places, Hashem is more accessible, we feel
Hashem presence more in Eretz Yisrael. And so
he suggests, on Yom Tov we're supposed to
feel those feelings of the day. In Eretz
Yisrael we feel connected to Hashem much more,
so you could just, it takes one day.
One day, you got the feelings of the
Yom Tov. But in chutz l'aretz, where Hashem
presence is further away, so you need two
days to get to it. You need two
days of Yom Tov. After two days of
Yom Tov, now I'll feel the Yom Tov.
Now I'll feel Kabbalas HaTorah on Shavuos. Now
I'll feel the cheirus of Pesach. Now I'll
feel the hashgacha and love of Hashem on
Sukkos. I need two days because in chutz
l'aretz we're so much further. Maybe even on
a simple, very practical, simple level, I don't
know if you guys have felt this this
year, probably have. You know, on Erev Shabbos
in Yerushalayim, it feels like Erev Shabbos. Right?
Stores are closing, people are getting ready for
Shabbos. That's the atmosphere. So then when you
get to Shabbos, you're right there, you're ready
to go. I remember when I, my first
Shabbos back after Shana Bet in America, I
went to Manhattan for Shabbos. Anyone here from
Manhattan? No? So I went to Manhattan for
Shabbos. So I remember, I had just spent
two years in the Old City, living here.
You know what Shabbos is like here in
the Old City. I was in Manhattan. I
walked out of the apartment I was staying
in to go to shul Friday night. Whoa,
cars are whizzing by, people are down, a
million people on the street, everyone, this isn't
Shabbos. They're okay, they're not Jewish, it's okay.
It was not Shabbos. It didn't feel like
Shabbos at all. So when you go into
Shabbos like that, that's how I went to
shul Friday night. It's much, takes more time
to start to feel Shabbos. Here, you're already
Erev Shabbos, everyone's winding down, everyone's getting ready,
you're getting in the atmosphere, the music's on
the streets. Oh, then you go into Shabbos
and take advantage. Same thing with Yom Tov.
So perhaps that's on a simple level, on
a more metaphysical level, HaKadosh Baruch Hu presence,
but bottom line is in Eretz Yisrael we
have an easier time feeling those connections. chutz
l'aretz they have a harder time feeling those
connections. And it's Chazal, as he points out,
Chazal do things, there's a lot of depth
to everything Chazal does, do. So on a
simple level, pshat, they gave us Yom Tov
Sheini because of this concern that there might
be a time in the future where you're
gonna need to keep it really misafek. But
there was, on another level, there was a
lot of gain from having Yom Tov Sheini
because it allowed us more time to connect
with Hashem. We'll say later, we'll say something
beautiful from a mefaresh on the second half
of this shiur. That's Yom Tov Sheini. Any
questions on Yom Tov Sheini other than the
exact question of which we'll get to after.
So far so good? Let's move on. The
next major, the major topic for our shiur
is, the major topic for our shiur is
what do you guys do? What do people
do who visit Eretz Yisrael from chutz l'aretz
and really vice versa? What about if I'm
visiting from Eretz Yisrael to chutz l'aretz? And
the answer to this question on a simple
level is a Mishnah Psachim. We learned Masechet
Psachim this year, I don't think anybody learned
this perek, but let's learn a Mishnah Psachim.
Source five, everybody take a look. Source five.
Makom shenahagu laasos melacha b'arvei Psachim ad chatzos
osin. So there was, there was a minhag
in some places. Well, we're gonna see makom
shenahagu shelo laasos eino oseh. There were different
minhagim about whether you were allowed to go
to work and do work on Erev Pesach
in the morning. In the times of the
Gemara, in times of Beis HaMikdash, in the
afternoon no one did melacha. But in the
times but there was there were different minhagim
about Erev Pesach in the morning. You allowed
to do melacha? Allowed to do laundry, all
kinds of things? So it depends on the
minhag on the makom. If you're in a
place where they do it, you got to
you could do melacha. If you're in a
place where they don't do melacha, you have
to follow the minhag and not do melacha.
minhag hamakom is binding. This is the this
is the mishna about minhag hamakom, one is
obligated to follow the custom in that place.
If the custom in your place is not
to do melacha, you have to go along
with the custom. Okay. What about if you're
moving around? Says the mishna: Haholech mimakom she'osin
lemakom she'ein osin. If a person goes from
the place where they do melacha to the
place where they don't, o mimakom she'ein osin
lemakom she'osin, or he goes from a place
where they don't do melacha to a place
where they do. What do you do then?
Nostin alav chumrei makom sheyatza misham vechumrei makom
shehalach lesham. So he says you have to
follow the stringencies of both. If you're going
from you're going from this might be my
son calling from school. Okay, hopefully. Give me
one second. Let's pause. Oh
no. All right, let's go on. The guys
in my shiur know that this phone is
only called by the school and I didn't
know the number but it was some someone
trying to sell me something. Anyway, so that's
the Gemara says if you this mishna says
if you go from one place to the
other Ari, you go from one place to
the other, you have to follow the stringencies
of both places. So if you live in
a town where they do work, but now
you find yourself in somewhere else, you have
to follow those stringencies. Likewise, if you're from
a town where they don't do work and
now you go over to a place where
they do work, you still can't work because
you got to maintain your practice. And the
Gemara explains that it depends on whether your
intention is to go back. If you move,
right, you're allowed to move places. So if
you move and you're not intending to go
back to your original place, so then you
follow the customs of that place. But if
you're intending to go back, you have the
stringencies of both. Says the concludes the mishna:
If you're intended to go back, you have
to keep the stringencies of both. I.E., I.E.,
if your practice if you come from a
locale where they don't do work, you can't
say oh when I'm visiting over there I
can do it. No, no, you're from that
place, you have to maintain that practice. And
concludes the mishna: ve'al yishaneh adam mipnei hamachlokes.
One should not deviate because due to the
concern of machlokes. Namely, let's say you come
from a place where they do work, right?
It says not doing work Erev Pesach. You're
allowed to do work, you're allowed to do
your thing on Erev Pesach. But why is
it they have to be strict when you
go visit the place where they don't do
work? mipnei hamachlokes. All this everyone nobody here
does work. All of a sudden you're going
to start doing work? That's going to cause
a rift. That's going to not people are
going to get upset. What are you doing?
Hey, no one does this here. Why are
you doing this? You have to follow the
practices of that of that place where you're
in now even if that's not really your
place because you're returning home to avoid machlokes.
This is the mishna in Pesachim. You just
learned this mishna. What should be the halacha
about someone from chutz la'aretz who's visiting Eretz
Yisrael? What should be the halacha based on
this mishna? We said if you're planning on
going back, you have to keep your original
practice. You have to keep your original practice.
If you didn't do melacha at home, you
can't do melacha in the place you're visiting.
So that's what the Beis Yosef in source
6 we have the Tshuvos Avkas Rochel which
was written by the Rav Yosef Karo the
author of the Shulchan Aruch. He was asked
this question. Truth is the the question you
see there is actually the opposite question: What
if you're from Eretz Yisrael and you're visiting
chutz la'aretz? But he says tshuva in the
second line, third line over there where he
says the answer davar pashut. He says it
is pashut, it is simple. dechol sheda'ato lachzor
noheg kemakom sheyatza misham. Anyone whose intention is
to return back to his original place, he
practices like the place which he left from.
afilu lehakeil, even to be lenient. uvilvad shelo
ya'aseh bifnei bnei makom shehalach lesham. As long
as you don't do your leniencies in front
of the people who are there. So what
he's talking about here is let's say you
are an Israeli, and for you to keep
you have one day of Yom Tov, that's
where you're from. That's your your practice. You're
going to chutz la'aretz where they keep two
days. So you follow your own practice, even
to be lenient. Even to I'm not going
to say Kiddush on the second day because
it's not Yom Tov for me. uvilvad shelo
ya'aseh bifnei bnei makom shehalach lesham. That's the
mishna, right? ve'al yishaneh adam mipnei hamachlokes. You
shouldn't do.